I was never raised to be a racist
there's never a part of my life ago I
was in prison I was born out of your
vasectomy you have to change who you are
[Music]
when he come to jail you come to prison
you got your white gangs and got your
black gangs if you step outside of that
you're not only going to have one enemy
you're going to have to the tattoo for
me was definitely like a shield the day
I got released I was determined not to
give up and say that's who I am and I
realized that I can change this my name
is Dave Calif and we run Redemption ink
I have been tattooing for over 20 years
we help people get a second chance by
removing racist and gang tattoos for
free we started about six months ago
I've done 16 cover-ups now the demand
for this to be honest with you it's
overwhelming i'ma try and do it at least
once a week either here at conventions
you know until I just can't tattoo any
more people are just going full-bore
trying to get help and most of them
might have to say that they're already
moved on they just still have the
tattoos that are holding them back like
I'm glad that I have a talent that I can
help somebody those people deserve the
paddle in the back not me they did what
they needed to do to change their lives
the end of the day I do want my daughter
picking up on that message I didn't want
my daughter thinking like that type of
thinking is right or asking me where I
got it or why I got it she doesn't have
to see any of that and I'm just like
grateful for that every day that you
never have they see me as that first
[Music]